[Music]
welcome back to the rock stars this is
the boys underground where we break down
and chat about amazon's darkest horrific
live-action superhero show uh i'm
jessica clemons here with brandon
barrick hello hello hello hello and
marina mastro hey
yes returning returning for the boys oh
my god just for the boys just for the
boys just for the boys you guys we're
gonna talk about all three episodes of
the boys season three today but first we
want to talk about all of our awesome
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com right now you can
get our latest obsession shirt empire's
most wanted inspired by the obi-wan
kenobi series on disney plus and if you
purchase this limited edition shirt you
get an option to unlock a shout out
which will be uh shown on our wikileaks
show which is our obi-wan kenobi after
show hosted by eric voss and tommy
bechtold we got tons of awesome obi-wan
kenobi merch some summer merch options
pride merch options you could see it all
over at
newrockstarsmerch.com that was a big
three-episode drop
so this is we're gonna break down
uh the three episodes that we just
watched for season three that dropped
yesterday at like 5 p.m coincidentally
and we'll be here recapping literally
every episode of the boys going forward
uh so before we even get into the mess
that we saw from last night let's recap
season two shall we yes let's let's do a
little quick recap because it's been
almost two years since two years two
years there's so much i had to look up
okay let's get started after being
framed for stillwell's a murder huey
chemical frenchie and mother's milk go
into hiding and begin trying to prove
their innocence meanwhile stormfront the
nazi homeland or love interest becomes
the newest member of the seven it's also
revealed now that vat is actually a
pharmaceutical company and compound v is
their most valuable asset through a
series of real unfortunate events
butcher and becca reunite but with
butcher not wanting anything to do with
ryan homelander and becca's son becca
refuses to run away with him homelander
and stormfront then take ryan with the
ideals he'd be better fit around other
supes and further push in their nazi
agenda the group finds out stormfront is
in fact a nazi basically compound v
patient zero and extremely dangerous
with homelander so they devise a plan to
save ryan and take out stormfront
stormfront gets curb stomped by kimiko
maeve and starlight in a beautiful fight
it's a good beat down
my mom rewound that scene so many times
i wish i could clip it and make it my
like phone
yeah becca like stabs her in the eye
yeah
just get a bunch of girls to beat above
the girl
i was so into it but unfortunately as we
know uh stormfront retreats and is about
to kill becca when ryan laser beams her
entire body and accidentally kills becca
his mom in the crossfire butcher
promises to take care of ryan homelander
weeps over stormfront our nautical hero
the deep spent the season taking some
questionable counseling through the
church of the collective but is a
changed man by the end of it with a new
wife at his side a train has just come
out of his coma following his compound v
induced heart attack and also uses the
church to maneuver his way back into the
seven maid uses the footage of flight 37
as blackmail to keep homelander away
from her and elena victoria newman
congresswoman anti-soup activist turns
out to be a soup who can make people's
heads explode what a season it was
the season season two was so jam-packed
and clearly my favorite season so i want
to see what season three has to offer
but like
season two was so good it was legit it
was so good it had so much juicy it was
so juicy so juicy i mean this season
started off pretty juicy oh my god not
too juicy
oh man
that was a rough 12 minutes to start
that
12 minutes i love that they were like oh
you forgot what the boys really liked
you had two years to think that we got
soft
we did it we got worse no no we got one
specific choice of words i did see a
great gift we'll get into what happens
in the episode but when butcher has
termite in the little bag the gift was
like uh me when i get that fun dip pouch
it's like shaking around a little bag
i know a lot of people would pay good
money to have that treatment oh
let's talk about uh episodes one two and
three we'll recap them real quick uh
you've all seen them so let's let's go
through a quick we open at the premiere
of dawn of the seven mother's milk has
stopped chasing after soups and gone
back to his family huey is now working
with victoria newman at the federal
bureau of superhuman affairs kimiko and
frenchie work with butcher catching
supes without killing them they're doing
it the good way they're doing it the
right way all is well
that is until huey discovers that his
boss victoria newman is the head popping
soup from the previous season and is
related to head honcho of vaude stan
edgar related through adoption
but he's getting real cozy with her
uh maybe two old
daughters if he's sitting that close to
a
stranger reading her a book i don't know
very very bizarre i'm glad she called it
out i'm glad you called it
it was a little bizarre uh there's a new
24-hour version of the compound v that
maeve sneaks to butcher he resists it
first but can't help but try it out uh
in part of his interrogation of the soup
gunpowder which was great
starlight has just been named co-captain
of the seven seeing as her ratings are
higher than homelanders right now which
drives homelander to absolute madness if
you didn't think he was mad enough yeah
he gets a little bit crazier a little
bit crazier i was really fascinated with
him watching
the movie because i think he does he
really loves
stormfront i mean he loves himself more
than anything yes do you think he really
loved her
i think at the end of the day it was her
praise of him that he loved yeah and she
oh how much she idolized she did she
recognized his power where stillwell was
wrong stormfront put him on a pedestal
he was the nazis like mission they were
like you're a superhero
you're the uberman
like yeah so i think he loved having
someone there that was
24 7 reminding him of how good he was
and how everyone else is wrong yeah
which someone that doesn't have a mother
would probably have those issues of like
not to be devil's advocate for old
laughter well yeah i did i was almost
feeling bad for homelander cause he's
like oh he has to watch this movie that
he said where's charlie's there on what
what a poll what a pulse she's having
the summer of you know that she was on
set for one day and got paid and she was
like thank you thank you thank you thank
you but i was kind of feeling bad he's
like oh yes watch this movie a fake
narrative about how he had to fight his
own his own love but then i was like no
he's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah once he uh quoted a martin luther
king
i know oh my god
there's so many times because we're
doing this show i won't turn it off but
i don't know how many times i've been
embarrassed for them i was like when he
was like
me and martin luther king kind of the
same person and i was like and he
started reciting it i was like stop him
stop him someone's telling him
well yes
our good buddy homelander confides every
day to stormfront who is still barely
alive and with only one remaining limb
which she puts to some use uh and a
severely burnt body uh i i i was
surprised to see that she was still
being kept alive and in homelanders room
very very interesting uh but later on in
an episode she million dollar babies
herself
uh driving homelander even crazier by
committing suicide and on his birthday
how could she the poor man's birthday
homelander on live television denounces
everyone who doesn't praise him and
compares himself to jesus and his
ratings shoot through the roof he uses
his newfound popularity to keep a close
eye on starlight by announcing to the
world that they are now dating much to
the surprise of starlight but because
she needs to keep herself alive she
leans into it uh the gang decides they
need to stop homelander once and for all
with the weapon that allegedly killed
soldier boy a very powerful soup during
the iran contra affair uh and the last
people to have that weapon was the
russians they made the weapon they ran
away with the weapon and possibly ran
away with soldier boy
i think it's also good to know allegedly
the russians i don't right trust crimson
i don't trust her when she came crying
did it seem at all like real oh yes yes
i know that she's weeping over
chimpanzees not crying like 40 years
later great son
so good when chemical was into the music
i was like
let's like keep playing i was watching
it with the captions on and i was like
she's not saying chimps and then i was
like she's saying champions
which is also
fun fact a true fact chips can't cry
doesn't mean emotionally they can't feel
anything but they can't cry um and i
think so side note some major points in
these episodes also take away in episode
one we immediately get a flash of the
soldier boy statue that we saw in season
two episode seven uh during homeland
order and stormfront's rally and i think
that's good to note because this is the
movie scene we see it like toppled over
and all the debris and it's like okay so
not only is this right now in this city
but we're still acknowledging homeless
or soldier boy soldier boy is a guy that
is very powerful i don't think
homelander has a statue does he
they have in the in the building in the
building in the building
like paintings yes freezes of all the
heroes
all over the place uh do real quick
about that movie
did they fake a train's
power in that movie because he can't run
right he doesn't want to run or maybe or
he just did it from here to here like
yeah like a little quick one yeah i
thought it was just like even a little
bit like give him a heart attack i mean
what a life yeah what a true life we
also we also see black noir in the movie
we haven't seen him in present day the
last we saw him in season two uh may
force fed him and almond joy which he
has the allergy to tree nuts which we
saw uh brought up in the flashback to
the ir uh the events down in nicaragua
as well
yes yes yeah cause she was like i've
never been there and then during before
the season released they did like kind
of some episodes on youtube that show
the the network show
where they all get interviewed that we
see in this season they did some clips
uh before the season came out kind of
like catching up with the heroes where
they were they say on that show that
black noise still alive and he's out
hunting a serial killer somewhere but
i'm wondering if he's maybe still in a
coma maybe still very sick maybe still
out there somewhere because you could
fake him in the movie you just put
anyone in the house oh yeah for sure
that is also true that's interesting
that's so funny if they do that because
they did that with we'll get into it
termite the superhero that we see uh at
the beginning oh my gosh it shrinks down
to miniature size and jumps in what you
think is a butthole but it's not a
bottle i thought it was a butthole we
all thought it was a butthole yeah yeah
i was like oh he's gonna go in the bike
oh it's not gonna go when he was like i
want you inside me i was like oh they're
just gonna have sex
as soon as that line was said i was like
this guy's gonna get smashed you're
smarter than i am though i was like
the writer said we're so tired of marvel
not talking about it we're gonna rack
yeah i mean frenchie being afraid that
he's gonna go up the butt and
get real big
the ant-man thanos theory finally put
into practice and we saw it we visibly
saw it so that um i think you guys
remember but if you don't he's in season
one episode one in the sex club when
huey and um butcher go to the sex club
he's the one that dives in if you will
uh he runs at a full sprint and then he
goes
uh and then in the comics we see him in
herogasm which is also an episode that
is like episode like six years like
halfway through the season and it's
something where uh uh the guy who played
the man who played soldier boy the actor
uh he was saying like that was a very
awkward episode to film so we'll see how
it could be any more awkward than
anything we've seen on the show before i
don't know i think from the comics hero
orgasm is
the comic like everyone's always like
everything can come back to hero game
that's like that's the red wedding of
this yeah
the secretary of defense robert singer
played by jim beaver whom we first met
in season one is now running for
president which is bad news i think
because he clearly is in vaught's pocket
well he used to run right was it
anything like a higher up at five i
think so i think or on the board or
something like that i mean that's
usually how it works yeah he has some i
mean he's doing so that's a little real
life coming into you right there
politicians involved in businesses i
don't want to get into it
the only place
this is it was only um i was only
skeptical because i was mainly like uh
but i mean maybe for the best that he
didn't want the compound v he was like
no this is tied to a nazi i don't want
it
i i found it really interesting in that
scene that he was having uh uh where
they were talking about like i don't
want he's saying i don't want vod to
have the superheroes they're the
problems yeah they're the pro i want to
be a pharmaceutical company and a
weapons company and these heroes that we
have to babysit yeah they're the big
problem which is very interesting uh if
you they want to find a way to kill all
the superheroes i don't know i mean
maybe that's what this weapon is for i
mean that's a great theory let's hold on
to that because there's later on i know
there's one that that could apply to
okay episode two uh at the orphanage i
think it's the red river orphanage yeah
that boy teleporting is madeline
stillwell's son teddy teddy stillwell
who they even call teddy stillwell
in the like script so you know that's
teddy steel even if the age and the
years might not seem like they line up
it is him it could be growing faster
he's gone that's what i think his super
powers is maybe like i age quickly too
well and because
a year went by so yeah yeah the house
the hot the house exploded but then he
was found teleported away yeah he
teleported from the danger which i think
is also great for a newborn baby
was able to teleport from heard a loud
noise went it just like zipped 17 miles
away from the house uh so that's a good
one in episode one uh season six or wait
in season one episode six uh oh okay can
i do this one yes because it's really
stupid this is just a stupid fight
this is a stupid fun fact that i really
love and i forgot
if you are like my mom and you were also
confused why a train went to seth and
said you have no dick it's because seth
was in season one episode six when huey
and um butcher went to
the like um it's like a support group
support group for superheroes that
affected actual normal civilians lives
seth had sex with ice princess who then
turned to negative 346 degrees the same
temperature as liquid nitrogen and in a
painful memory seth has of his dick
literally getting snapped off getting
snapped off so it's like a trade
literally brought them up to be the
meanest person in the world
it's so funny i mean that's a bad guy
he's a bad guy he's sexualizing 11 to 14
year old girls uh he's a bad guy and
then last fun fact is the shipment that
we see that's one uh 100 colombian black
noir coffee rose was actually in the 80s
uh used to ship cocaine or was thought
allegedly probably to ship cocaine
because dogs couldn't sniff the cocaine
uh through coffee coffee right so that
black noir is the symbol for the iran
contra yeah
if you don't know out there please look
up the iran contra affair and how ronald
reagan and oliver north were involved
it's a very shady business please do
that much of the show is true yeah that
much of the show is very true yeah so
let's get to the actual big questions on
the show those are just like fun facts
for you guys to look into the big
questions of the show
what did soulja boy do to mother
mother's milk family you know because
mother's milk a whole thing is like i'm
going to kill this man because he killed
my family and past seasons mother's milk
talked about his dad fondly but
something happened between him and
vaught where he tried suing him um he
would always hear his dad type typing on
his typewriter and then one day found
his dad hunched over dead at the
typewriter in the comic books his
brother died taking compound v and it
sent his dad spiraling do we think
soulja boy like now that we that's in
the comics not in the show do we think
soldier boy had anything to do with that
well when he was like kind of going
through his papers and like laying
everything out again that first article
it did say like it brought up like a
family caught in the crossfire in harlem
i was like oh is that is that him is
that mother's milk's family that was
killed and then there was a bunch of
other articles so i don't know i assume
it was some sort of like superhero
casualty
oh that would yeah sense and it still
would give you like vengeance to want to
kill it now if it's something where you
know they brought it up uh uh a train's
brother was bringing up how like you
know someone was killed by a superhero
maybe like falsely accused and it's just
like murdered in the street maybe
something happened similar to mother
smoke's family where soulja boy thought
he was going to kill some criminals and
he kills the wrong people yeah but we're
also wondering is soldier boy actually
dead no wednesday well in the trailer we
see a lot of him are the flashbacks that
we saw in nicaragua but there is one
scene where he is in like a tracksuit
longer hair disheveled looking clearly
and like sitting in the middle of the
ground we also see a shot of the city
like crumbling like a statue or monument
crumbling and i'm thinking what if
someone a part of mother's milk life was
in that crumbledness so he could still
enjoy the building yeah he could still
be dead and that flashback was from that
time not technically the 80s where the
iran contra affair happened but maybe
like the 90s oh okay
where the mother's milk did have a
brother that died or something
um i just feel like
i i no one's ever dead right but no
one's ever dead and soldier boy's got to
be alive well why would we spend so much
time yeah and like to be dead you do or
you don't i do
i really want him to be dead because i
think
it makes
it's not that makes more sense but i
think it's better for this the story
that it's just like
yeah he is dead
he's dead you're chasing nothing like
he's actually dead they think he's alive
the whole time it's like a macguffin i
mean we know how the you know this
series loves to kind of have all these
illusions to famous comic book stories
uh and famous comic book heroes this is
this seems like a strong allusion to the
winter soldier storyline right you take
a hero from america you take them over
to russia you brainwash them you change
them and it does seem like the russians
are trying to
this makes me think of like red guardian
right like they want to find their own
compound bee they want to make it them
themselves but i love this idea that
bots behind whatever russia is doing too
like they got to have their fingers
everywhere in the world and create their
own competition in a way i mean it makes
me think of like the space race right
the you know you have the the soviets
and the americans racing to space oh for
sure uh and there's a lot of theories
that uh a lot of soviet ass cosmonauts
died that we don't know about because
the soviets so tightly controlled the
news about what space programs they did
that they were watching a lot of people
in the space and the ones that didn't
work they never announced it and the
ones that did work they're like oh yuri
gagarin made it it's great there was ten
guys before him and maybe even there's a
big theory that they launched a woman
into space who died uh during the years
didn't want to say they didn't want to
bring it up because they they didn't
want to talk about it
well also like they took soldier boy's
body which if you think like if you've
if you developed a weapon to kill soups
why would you bother scooping the corpse
unless you need it to either maybe like
the weapon only works once and now he's
the weapon oh right like it absorbs or
something because so they had to take
the body with them because i was like
why would you like risk in a war time to
bother to take something like it's so
hard to do that you would just leave
yeah yeah you would just shoot shoots
and leave yeah exactly like what's the
point unless he they need him for
something
that's i think that's a trail to
like sniff out i think he probably they
probably just like paralyzed him for a
minute yeah and they were like we need
to take the body because also i think
it's easier to take his blood and his
stuff and test it to make other soups
rather than just like trying to make a
compound be on themselves so they
probably only paralyzed him and i think
that would make for good storytelling
too to be like we got the weapon but it
only like knocks you out
48 hours well i my theory is because we
saw we saw black noir uh in nicaragua
you see him without the mask he's
talking he's got a normal face
everything seems fine finally that actor
is probably like yeah that's what
my whole thing was always like i'm so
happy they made it work because i feel
like in the mandalorian it was really
hard for pedro pascal to take off his
mask because it's like well it's the
mandalorian coat to not take off your
mask but in this i'm like there's no
code he can take off his mask
i love that he doesn't want to wear it
he's like no it tastes better with young
kids if you're you're a silent ninja and
also like we can't have a black guy on
the seven is messed up or on payback or
whatever they were yeah during the like
the 80s still yeah
they're like it doesn't work it's not
good
but my theory is so we see that he got
very badly affected in his guard and we
know he doesn't heal up in the future
right yeah but he has healing factor
that's part of his thing i think
whatever this weapon was
it hit him
and it damaged him that's why he was
never able to heal from that's where he
got the peanut butter
yeah whatever this weapon was it didn't
kill somebody
because he wasn't the direct like yeah
yeah and i think black noir was there
when it happened he got hit uh and maybe
he can't even talk about it now he can't
even say what the weapon is because like
his voice has been destroyed by it and i
think you're right that the uh crimson
countess or whatever her name uh
she was it was just weird she was acting
very hard and everyone was like on the
ground helping each other and she went
oh
my goodness the boys so she's gotta do
uh six shows a day in vaughtland it's
very difficult
what what's the tastiest treat of
botland uh in in the maeve's pride
yeah something like that a donut burger
uh yeah was a woke walk
it was all bad my mom's favorite scene
was frenchie being like a burger made of
buns there is no god here
that is real though but i think that i
think that laser or whatever machine gun
is what actually did and it's really
hard for black nor black nor couldn't
even he was so hurt when he found out
that he was a test like subject and his
family is gone because he's been
spending like i think he's still a very
emotional person under that so he
probably doesn't want to talk about like
i can't take off the mask now because
i'm ugly yeah when he found out that
compound v was a thing he cried i mean
it broke his heart and the comics black
noir is like an exact copy of homelander
yeah like he was made as like a backup
to kill homelander which makes me wonder
with this show and with vi how have they
not come up with a way to kill him i
think the backup homelander is soldier
boy and uh they released he has a
problem too yeah yeah that when watching
the show that was my first immediate
response was they can't make a home
lander they can't make a superman
without them being bad right like and i
love this show for that because it's
like superman would have become a bad
person he would have recognized like
my favorite horrible monologue in this
season is homelanders straight up being
like yeah you can take that away from me
and i'll have nothing left and i'll just
kill everybody he's so clearly thought
about he's like first to take out the
nerves yeah
[Music]
i will come to the hit country over here
[Music]
yeah it's so true he's like i have
nothing to lose if you take that away
from me so i'll just go on because for a
second you feel like oh they got the
upper hand on him
edgar's not afraid of him at all they're
just going to do their thing
you know he's going to make starlight
captain it's fine but like he's he's
like deranged he's so far off he's so
especially with stormfront being dead
stillwell's gone
he can't see his son he wants to see his
son he must be a son on the plus side
speaking of his son
butcher might be the answer for killing
him possibly
no no no
no no killian uh killing homelander so
butcher's powers yeah the comics butcher
was injected with a permanent compound
vehicle they all take it they all take
it yeah uh it's what they gave them the
superpowers they needed to beat the
supes in this show though it looks like
he has the laser beams he has a super
strength bullets can't penetrate that
man you see it uh so kind of the same
but he can't smell he can't smell like
home or what we don't know we don't know
yet so he's getting used to it uh i
think i mean that's seen in the first
episode
of them talking that's the foreshadow
for the climax they want to have the
knock down dragon right right i think
they're going to have the man of steel
style style fight where they're just
like destroying a city
killing each other which is going to be
dark yeah we haven't seen butcher fly
yeah yeah fly that's true we haven't
seen that much yet do you think this
compound v will be permanent because i
don't think it's been 24 hours but he
hasn't taken a second one yet yeah i
don't know
but it does seem like there's still some
residual effects coming through and they
made it very clear that this compound v
24-hour version is not it's unstable
it's not foolproof they haven't fully
tested it and it's clearly killing some
people guys
i think i got something to add up to
that so we we got this character new to
the show nina also known as little nina
in the comic books uh she's a russian
crime boss she has her own version of
compound v that she got from vaught in
the comic books but the compound v that
they got was like bad it was bad
compound v and she staged a coop in
russia with her army supes and then blew
up all their heads so she could see like
she looks like they're taking control
she was like everyone was like oh my
gosh she defeated all these random soup
villains and it's like
she got bad compound v from vaught
so not only is she like a menace in the
comic books she clearly is a menace now
in the live show
do you think that compound v could have
been the compound v with nina so nina
could have the same compound v that's 24
hours that butcher's using
maybe i mean we haven't seen her using
powers yet but everyone's afraid of her
yeah everyone's in theory she has some
either her power is the power we hear so
much about the control the way to bend
the world or she has like physical
superhero powers i think she probably
should have something i love this idea
that she has like the russian version
it's just blue it's just beautiful
yeah oh yeah because they've had blue
was the real compound beads yeah blue 24
hours
green so there's a red oh russian red
well i didn't even know that the i
forgot about the color oh yeah i changed
the color a little bit oh i want her to
have i want them to be like like because
vaught has something up their sleeve
right now right and what better horrible
way for a company than to make a really
good product and sell it to politicians
in the u.s and then have a lesser
product and sell it to other countries
so i want vot to be like having that
underhand and being like we're actually
distributing both these compound fees to
two different people because we are a
pharmaceutical company yeah we're not a
superhero company so i think i want that
to be the case i want vod to be working
like under like this they are on contra
affair i want it to still be
like under the table they're like we're
still sneaking stuff yeah like don't get
that wrong yeah they're spreading their
weapons they're spreading the drugs all
over the world and they just want to be
in control of it it doesn't matter who
wins because they'll be in control yeah
and little nina in the comic books was
working with like the bot head heads up
they were like they were like
two heads
they were like this uh i also just think
it maybe it isn't good storytelling i
just like it that it is bad like the
compound v that butcher's taking when
he's like your blood smells funny i
don't want it to be because he's a soup
i want it because it's a chemical in his
body yeah that he's like
it smells weird now it's like i think he
is smelling smelling the the v the
twenty-four yeah because it's inside of
this
and that's something his dad could do
right homelander has good smell he's
used it before he could smell that like
huey and starlight were lying before
because their adrenaline guy got uh he
could smell the adrenaline thereby who
knew they were like he smelled
explosives before so he's just like his
dad which i also think
this show is kind of showing that even
with good parenting uh
it's a problem
it's a problem and when and man when
butcher you know told him off and was
like
you think i'm happy that you killed my
becca i was like oh that's his mom dude
he didn't want to do it either
you want to do it either you have to do
that impression more oh his voice is
great i love it i love sometimes i'm
like what are you saying
when he was like i was absolutely
chuffed i was like oh
when he was talking and using every like
made-up word for giving head i was like
to the gunpowder and i found powder but
in the bathroom he was like sloppy
knocker i was like what the hell
i was like what is this this is uh
what's the guy that does uh did aladdin
does all the like british mafia movies
guy richie
i was like is this a guy richie flick
i'm so confused
you know yes
took his dream to the dogs i was like
yeah i'm my dude i mean me too i guess
um but i
little nina is someone that we should be
looking for yeah um
this season playing a big role i know
that the fans are like oh because it's
also not little nina in the comics was
the
epitome of a young girl she was little
um they can't do that yeah i can't do
that
and i'm completely fine with that yeah
there's enough darkness in the show
enough real life in this show
because i you know homelander coming out
as an [ __ ] and being praised for it
is like too real that's too real that is
too real they are really good and that
was like the last thing we had against
him was like he had to have a good
public image and yeah he doesn't have to
i'm worried what is so what's the
overall plan so we have victoria newman
that showed up at uh in the second
season she's clearly blowing people's
not only heads she can blow body parts
her eyes turn away i love the
establishing this is a line-of-sight
thing you have to be she has to be able
to look at whatever she wants to blow up
is still so easy to do the and that tony
the person that knew her before yeah in
her past life knew that he had just had
to cover her eyes yeah you just need to
cover her eyes that's all you need to do
yeah so it's like
we have her clearly she might she's
probably bad because she
loves edgar
yeah she's going to do whatever he says
and i think it's bot's plan is to have
some their their main problem is the
government right yeah and they want to
have control of the government somehow
and it's like money has worked power and
influence has worked but let's just get
someone on the inside let's get our
manchurian candidate in there but what's
the like end goal because it just seems
like i understand like companies wanting
to own everything right amazon amazon
yeah i understand wanting to own
everything but there's always an end
goal you're not just trying to uh
yeah he's scrolling he's going through
amazon
the little shot of like amazon what was
he doing sorry he was buying connect
four oh yeah he was he was he was like
because i couldn't see i was like is he
on a dating app
because it's like connect and i was like
what what
he's he's like talking to it he's just
scrolling right he's looking for a new
background also butcher connect four
it's a little amateurish for ryan let's
get him into uh lords of water deep
let's get him into sellers i think it's
also light them into wings well this
game won't ever have to make him think
too hard yeah it is a logic game it's a
strategy game
is like for seven years yeah get him at
least get him into like a fellow or
something get him into trouble oh my god
oh he's in trouble oh he is in trouble
okay sorry so what's the so yeah what's
the end goal for like and victoria like
they're clearly merging yeah there's and
i don't want to i don't want any like
excuse of like they just want to own
everything i'm like i want to know what
the actual end goal is i don't think
vaughn wants to like destroy the
government or anything i think they just
want to have a fail safe there yeah but
if they need to destroy the government
they can uh she could just start popping
heads whenever she wants but i think
they just want to be able if legislation
starts going and gets them i mean he his
clear goal is to get supes back in the
army right that's what he's always
wanted
to do so maybe that's it and especially
because like he they're smart enough and
she's smart enough to know that you have
to be she's like the aoc version right
right
you know and so they would never vote
for somebody who's out and out
supporting this so they have to go about
it the other way yeah she's shutting
down soups she's locking them up exactly
the good way so if everybody thinks that
she is against this then probably end
goal presidency commanding the troops
that are on v yeah temporarily and if
need be they could she could order as
president the army to get rid of all
soups
like not like uh what are they called
like permanent suits yeah yeah yeah yeah
so she could order the army to get rid
of all permanent soups and then vat
would be set for life yeah that's but
that's like what i want to also we can
maybe talk about this next episode is
why is vat so important to edgar like
why is it so important to giancarlo
esposito because he's just like you're
gonna die eventually and vaught just
goes to someone else maybe maybe he is
gonna give vaught to victoria he's like
victoria's gonna take on my legacy maybe
or you know it's just while he's alive
he wants to have all the power he can
and he's worked his whole life with this
yeah that is true we saw a young a young
fun for that actor he did a great job it
was great
i was like that is him
it was someone trying to do an
impression
i got sold on it i was like he's doing a
good job of this little serious like
waiting said he stares down and looks up
a little bit face down eyes up yeah i'm
sorry i can't help you i'm sorry i would
like to do more for you so these are
questions now that i want theories to
what do we think will happen
now that the public thinks starlight and
homeland are a couple honestly
embarrassing
embarrassing girl oh girl and when i
when i was like
when huey said
uh layla he didn't say lay low you know
like that is i mean that was tough
you know that was some really good you
know thematic storytelling there showing
her beginning having to play this like
her own mother
forcing her to be this like
[Music]
11 year old like sexy singer singing
britney spears adding another layer to
the the darkness of all of that yeah the
makeup the dancing and like hey yeah
yeah with that like closed fists like
squeezing so hard and you know putting
that in at the end i think this was a
misstep by homelander because by doing
this it gives her even more power and
now in public she can kind of force him
into things he tried to force him into
donating the money he said no to that
he shut that down he said no that was
good but i think by putting them
together
i think it's a misstep by him i think it
gives her a little a little more power i
think it's a misstep for him but it's
also still like a misstep for her
because now and this might be me coming
from just like the
civilian perspective that i'm like now
she's tied to this man that dated the
nazi like
i think like his viewer but luckily his
viewership went up i guess but like i
just think it's stirring more of a
ruckus and more crime will probably
happen and people will associate her
with him now
it might be also that like she has to
stay with him and with him probably
maybe even in like close quarters
so
but if the point is to get a weapon that
kills him that might be the only way
that they can get closer that is true
and that is if she has to like oh but
like honestly just embarrassing like the
age difference i was like
everything everything about it when she
had to kiss him i was like oh stop it i
was like punch him in the face punch him
in the stomach like huey and sterling
just have like a full season together
it's like every season they gotta break
them up i mean i i could tell from the
first episode when huey's looking sharp
looking great in a suit you were like
this will not work the palatine making
his smoothies
the aqua fresh everyone's looking up to
him and it's like this is not gonna be
so good to meet you what's
wave right what does he do with his
power he's fast he's a he's another
runner oh really oh yeah yeah
they have they still runner now they
just added another have more running
because i was so stuck on him being a
boy band by himself
what is his power is he just singing i
think he's just sexy he's fast i think
they establish she's a he's a runner i
felt bad for huey then too because they
when he was talking to the van to
starlight or the trailer i was like yeah
yeah i mean jealousy is never a good
look no no but like feel confident in
your relationships don't be jealous yeah
don't be jealous but i was like i'm not
gonna be mad
i mean i she was uh she was a little too
friendly
[Applause]
but yeah i hope i hope that he's genuine
i like i it was very it was very good of
him to be like yeah i'm here to help you
yeah i'm not gonna leave you in this
situation that's why i also tried to get
him out yeah she did and i think that's
another reason why she decided to fake a
relationship with homelander is like not
only to like stay low and stay on the
plan was to protect him because he is
clearly he already said the most racist
to him behind behind the camera and then
have the audacity to speak spanish to
him on camera and then starlight was
like he will tear you apart yeah he
hasn't like fully broken me down because
i'm also a white woman like i am a
blogger and he's emotionally unstable
and i think she can manipulate him that
kiss is a is a manipulation yes yeah as
awful as that is to do
no it's just i don't even want her to
have to do it right now i want her to
have to do it baby and then they brought
the deep back
they broke the deep back
lastly this is a question i had as soon
as i watched it i said how did she get
all that medical equipment storm front
how does she how is she alive or like
how does everyone know she's alive and
also do they just think that she is half
dead
from nothing do they know that it's the
child well they so they've told this
movie has come out so i think the well i
would take it as the dawn of the seven
is the narrative they're putting out
there oh but they all they found out
she's a nazi and they all got together
and they fought her but also there's a
press conference at the end of season
two and he says like she's been captured
she's been
neutralized or something but we have her
oh
okay that makes me serious she still has
all these supporters all these um fans
carrying tiki torches again the real
life really
really thrown in our faces in this whole
situation but what i found most
interesting is that they release the
fact that she committed suicide
on their own news network and that's
very manipulative in a very strange way
because again i think they're playing
both sides on this where they're like
yes we're against nazis we're of course
we're getting nazis but also like hey
nazis look what they did to you yeah you
know i think i think they're playing it
both ways
stan edgar does say in season two she's
good at making people mad yeah she's
good and i think i feel like this is uh
something for the audience and for
everyone to take away we need to
remember that this show does piss people
off at sometimes because they have to
feed to both like narratives because if
they don't feed to both narratives it's
not real life yeah it's not real life
you think the news is only feeding does
well it usually does uh one side
they just need to make so i think it's
not only mirroring us but it's like
you get more clicks you get more looks
at when you're actually fighting against
what's right like so i think that's what
all of vaughn media is it's like we're
giving her credit yes they're creating
disorder
do you think she committed suicide or do
you think she was killed i think she did
i think she did bite off her tongue and
killed herself because she's one item
and she was ignoring him she was like
you don't have autism you don't care
about being the uber mensch the uber the
uber driver you don't care about being
the uber driver you don't care about
riding the boat you don't care about
getting five stars yeah what what's
wrong with this you didn't talk to me so
i yeah probably because also who could
kill her if the if ryan couldn't kill
her with like a well it's also last i
guess that's that's yeah
that's why i think she might have been
like killed a different way i don't know
maybe there was the blood on the bed
right oh yeah because i was like do you
bleed if you choke well if you bite off
your own you're gonna bleed but she
barely could move so she had to like
really laugh and it was a little bloody
it wasn't a ton of blood someone
probably just stabbed her maybe like
well she's still she got stabbed in the
eye i don't know that's a good question
so maybe her maybe her uvula is like her
weak point if you stab her you know what
yeah cause like it
so many things where if you just do one
per one thing to a soup they're like
yeah yeah yeah normally that's right
tree nuts
is just cutting out her uvial right so
her tongue is her weakest
our biggest questions and biggest
takeaways from this is is stormfront
actually dead uh is soulja boy actually
dead
right right so are the people that are
dead actually dead where is this going
to be taking homelander and stormfront
what is bot and victoria newman's like
ultimate goal yeah
and i think these are things that we
will figure out as the show goes on and
hopefully
do you think who do you think is going
to be taken down do you think it's going
to be actually bought this season or do
you think it's going to be homeland or
finally i i think this has to be the
season they deal with homework yeah i
don't think he can keep being the big
bad i i would love to have that epic
battle between
uh butcher and homeland
both souped up
it's uber destructive and maybe neither
of them walks away i don't know if you
could have this show without butcher
though i mean come on you got it it is
so great do you think this is so this is
like the season where
i think someone dies someone big has to
die this season it's been seasons
waiting right none of them have well
like stillwell dying was huge for season
one right uh stormfront being
neutralized and becca dying is big
becca's
but it's not something that has been
here since the beginning so it has to be
like chemical frenchy
mother's milk oh that's mother's mouth
none of them please do not kill mother's
milk with his like he's like i got a
family i i was worried about he's he's
into it he's into a roommate no he's in
the homeland he's in the homeland did
you remember
who was step dad the step-dad
he dressed up as homelander too which
again yeah he did
poor mother's milk having to go to his
daughter's birthday party
the the man who has come in to replace
him no step dads are fine
but
he dressed up as homeless yeah
and who actively is doing and his
ex-wife is like i know this isn't cool
yeah you know it's not cool
come on and then i at first i was like
i'm gonna give them i'm gonna give them
a pass the the family because they're
black and then at the rally in the
trailer there's a lot of black people at
the homeland rooting for him so it is a
diverse rally and i'm
tired of it
in real life
they said he i could have a beer with
him i said he married a nazi
the number one nazi you guys we
give us feedback tell us tell us what
you want to hear more i'm actually going
to survive this season ashley um getting
her hair ripped
oh my god how does she sell someone's
hair i literally i re-watched season two
thinking she was dead already
and was surprised that she had not died
because i was like oh yeah she died in
season two
though i love ashley too actually too
it's great
oh my god i'm sorry ashley
my favorite my favorite part about
ashley was so much in these three
episodes she's doing great yeah of is
pull my hair no pull it out
oh my god
tony gilroy had to reshoot all your
scenes so many good filmmaker references
tony gilroy
just great stuff go ahead and uh give us
your guys's a little underground of what
you saw in the episode that we didn't
talk about on the boys underground and
that is it for this episode you guys we
summed up three episodes yeah season
three it is crazy maybe be over 18 to
watch it
oh my god oh my gosh
uh yeah we'll be back here every friday
breaking down the boys
here at the boys underground please tune
in please keep your kids away from this
show i don't know what to tell you yeah
you think it's a butthole and then
you're like why is that
i thought it was a butthole and i was
like weird butthole would a butthole
have been better i don't know better or
worse
i would have been okay with it oh thank
you brandon thank you marina uh follow
brandon at grindenberric follow marina
marina masteros uh follow me at lulu
underscore clemens follow new rockstars
here on youtube and on all social media
make sure to hit that notification bell
and be sure to check out our new
rockstars discord you have to be 18 plus
just like to watch the boys
so make sure you tune in and tune in to
our tumblr yeah um i'm over there going
crazy a little bit sometimes it's a lull
i got a lot of stuff to do um but check
us out next friday when we do a recap of
episode four season three
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you